how do you stay positive how do you stay
i positively love my job that actually
is easy that part
you love your job i really do you wake
up and you go
here you go
yeah i'm not joking like oh my god
how do you do that not every job is as
stress-free and
kind and we've built a community
well you i always say this because i've
heard this is like the lead actor sets
the sort of the mood of the show listen
i've been the lead actor on stressful
jobs i i haven't changed at all
sometimes it's just
there's a
cornucopia of things that can happen to
make it stressful sometimes it's
stressful beyond your control right i
wish it were up to me every time was
castle stressful
castle was stressful just if not just
for the schedule alone
it was an intense schedule five days a
week or six days a week but five and
sometimes six
and how did you cope with that uh not
well you can look at photos of me during
that time i just get kind of more tired
and bloated as years go on
well how did you get through it because
there's been moments where i i've seen
other actors or i've seen myself going
how am i gonna get through this yeah how
how do you i'm just so tired i'm just so
tired
passes and then eventually there's a
light at the end of the tunnel and then
you kind of aim at that and then when it
ends that's the thing it's finite right
it's not going to last forever you can
make it well what about therapy do you
go to therapy i've gone to therapy
i don't feel any pressing problems that
are haunting me i'm a pretty happy guy
you are a pretty happy guy yeah you're
pretty chill who do you talk to when you
have things on your mind like who is my
brother all the time i got a couple of
buddies i'll talk to alan tudyk all
doctors
yeah we've been buddies for a long time
yeah since serenity
uh before that fire firefly and before
that
he was my burrito waiter in new york
city when i was working on soap and he
was attending juilliard he was what the
favorite my favorite burrito place we
realized years later that he worked
there that he worked there while i was
attending he was actually my waiter on
more than one occasion
he told you that we realized together we
we kind of came to that and now you've
been friends for how long
oh only 20 years
join us every week as we discuss all
that is smallville we're going to watch
every episode that's right with you
talkville the ultimate smallville
podcast we're gonna go way back join tom
welling and michael rosenbaum every week
as they rewind every episode of
smallville and discuss their experiences
with friends fans and co-stars tockville
the ultimate smallville podcast